a company's built their brand on having
a certain set of audience that's who
they draw
let's just say pick a product you know
if you got
fox news republicans cnn democrats
msnbc far left espn
sports you know you go to yahoo
horoscope
cert not anyways you go to all these
different places how do you
see this because a company has biggest
victoria's secret
who's known who their customers for the
longest time
and who buys their stuff who to appeal
to
how do you view and justify a company
that big with a ceo to say
look we're going to go in a completely
different direction we're not going to
have our
you know the the what do you call it
they're angels anymore that you see and
all this stuff
the girls now we're gonna go we're gonna
get activists we're gonna go on a
complete different angle
we're not gonna go to that route how do
you justify to say yeah they're doing
the right thing they're going the right
direction versus saying they're about to
pay a price for it
well they are going to pray they are
going to pay a price for it and
so one of the things that i do in my say
when i'm teaching mba classes
and i'm doing all this evolutionary
stuff i i want to kind of
assuage the the worry of my students
because they feel as though they've
wrongly fallen into the wrong class some
biology class rather than some mba
course in consumer behavior
and i tell them you know be patient
because it's all going to come together
i'm teaching you now
the universal explanations for human
behavior
but then i will give you some very
practical implications in
in marketing so and so to address your
question let me give one such example
so if you look at romance novels romance
novels are almost exclusively
read by women all around the world there
is there's not a single culture where
that
phenomenon is reversed so if i want to
study
female preferences i could look
at the archetype of the male hero in a
romance novel
to see what what is it that women
fantasize about when they are consuming
such a product and it turns out that
it's always the exact same guy it's as
if it's plagiarized
across every single romance novel that's
ever been written patrick's what is he
he's tall he is socially dominant he is
a count meaning a prince and a
neurosurgeon
he is reckless and a risk taker he
wrestles
alligators on his six-pack but he could
only be tamed by the love of this one
good good woman
i just shaved i just saved you the
the the heartache or or the effort of
having to read every romance novel
that's ever been written i should have
never had 50 shades of gray
exactly so now let's so that's my next
point now
is going to bring home the the the
question that you asked
so a few years ago a company i don't
remember their name uh was a progressive
company they wanted to create a new line
of romance novels
that extricated themselves from this
archetypal view
of the toxic masculine man and so they
created
a new line where the guy you know is
sensitive he cries all the time he sucks
his tongue he watches bridget jones
diary
well guess what happened the consumers
in this case called
women said sorry not interested that's
not what i fantasize about when i'm
trying to escape in a romance novel so
if you do things as a company
that violate fundamental tenets of human
nature
the market has a very clever way of
correcting your
misconceptions so i always tell my
students
ultimately a good marketer is one who
understands human nature whether they've
taken my courses or not
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
you